the longest remaining stretch of the
Berlin Wall is the 1,300 meter long East
Side Gallery people from all over the
world come to see it and the paintings
on it in 1990 an international group of
artists created the imaginative often
political works to celebrate the end of
Berlin's and Europe's Cold War division
this is my first time here and I'm
really impressed when you walk up close
to the wall is still incredibly
impressive that's amazing it really is
we've taken some photos and they very
recognizable like you can understand you
can see a few of the images that are
around the world even from Australia
I've seen some of these images before so
it's incredible some of the familiar
motifs the East German Trabant car
bursting through the wall the Brezhnev
Honaker kiss or Connie Olive ease it
happened in November you know we knew
very well that we were making a small
contribution to this peaceful revolution
by creating the East Side Gallery know
so many millions of people come here
every year to see this symbol of culture
and people coming together that's
fabulous for us to see in his apartment
right by checkpoint charlie
Connie Ella we made the studies for his
picture about the hopes and fears people
had as
the former Ally checkpoint at the Berlin
Wall is another favorite spot for
visitors to Berlin
among other things they can pose for
souvenir photos with make-believe army
officers
and have their day passes stamped
displays describe checkpoint Charlie's
dramatic role in the Cold War I think
it's more important to be here - to see
a very sorry of German Germany and
Europe it's a good way to show to people
what happened and to put people aware
about that the the history didn't repeat
in this way the third site devoted to
the wall and the events leading to its
collapse is the Berlin Wall memorial on
Bernauer Strasse a 70 meter long stretch
of the border strip has been preserved
here including a watchtower from a
viewing platform visitors can get an
authentic impression of the barrier
that's so effectively separated the two
Germany's
on a 1.4 kilometer stretch along very
narrow straw so the memorial tells the
story of the building of the wall and of
the fates of those who tried to overcome
it
out Friedrich seventeen-years-old shot
dead on November 27th 1962 the window of
remembrance commemorates the many
victims who died trying to cross the
wall only a few hundred metres from the
memorial is mauerpark a popular meeting
place along the former death strip
on Sundays a flea market attracts
tourists and Berliners alike to the park
and impromptu karaoke contests have
become a well-known institution even
beyond the German capital